i
must be careful with what
our mother nature has given us, which is
clay, it is flexible, it lends itself to doing
what we want
at the same time that we are
doing something and we are already thinking about what it is going to
take in that piece so that  have that
texture that resistance and it stays as
we see what is better we
speed up our hands so as not to take
so long to finish a piece
[Music]
since my grandparents they worked with
glazed pottery but they were utilitarian things
with the passage of time  He was
adding more to it, the proportion was given
little by little, they were
turning into pineapples
since my childhood, because I saw
my grandfather work right away, my dad, but
I never thought that one day I would be able to work
pineapples
[Music]
I feel that my children are going  to
follow up on this work because it is a
culture that our ancestors left us with,
we have mud, which is the main thing,
right away we have the water that with the
two materials we managed to continue
maintaining our culture
[Music]